good morning believe nation today's
message is do the best you can
over to you Jackie Chan every day when
it on the set I just do the best I can
every movie that I risk my life that you
do the things not for the the beginning
is not for the fans it for myself
because I have to do the best I can then
lately becoming my trademark Wow Jackie
really is the life boom boom yeah when
I'm making a movie after the finish the
movie is done I asked myself can my
movie showing my children yes then I let
my children to see it then if I my
children can see the whole world
children can see it so the thing that
really resonated with me in this video
was doing something that you're proud of
right you want to pour your heart your
soul into the products and services you
create and it should be something that
the end result you are proud of and I
loved when he said he wants to create
something that he can show his kids and
be proud of that's a great model right
you should love your product and service
so much that you would happily recommend
your mother or your grandmother to try
it out right if you are not using your
product and you're not that part of it
and you wouldn't tell your mother you've
got to use this then you shouldn't be
selling it and this is a big problem for
a lot of entrepreneurs who are in the
network marketing or affiliate marketing
industries where you've never actually
even used a product or service that
you're selling and there's no way you
would feel comfortable promoting it to
your mother that's a sure sign that the
business is not gonna work out you've
got to love your product the other angle
that I take from this is I don't try to
make everything perfect you know a lot
of people they don't release anything
yet because it's not perfect and they're
always tinkering and fine-tuning and
they never actually get anything out
there where yes perfection might be the
goal but it may not happen on the first
version and so even looking at these
videos if you go back and
to my channel how it's grown right and
every week if we make a mistake we'll
get a new idea I don't go back and fix
it I just worry about the next product
and the next vision in the next video
that we're gonna come up with always
trying to get better but not being so
caught up on it being perfect that you
don't release anything so my question is
day for you today is are you proud
enough of your product or service to
recommend it to your mother and
grandmother and why or why not leave in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spresso we got to get
this right because i can't do a lot of
chin-ups
no no retakes on this